we're now going to look at applications
of multi-objective least squares to the
general area of
control
so a general way to say what control is
it's something where you're going to
choose an action or an input
to achieve some desired output or result
so let's see how that looks um we'll
have an n vector x
that's going to correspond to our
actions or inputs by the way a very
traditional symbol for that is u
not x but we'll leave it as x here um
an n vector y is going to correspond to
the results
or the outputs of using the input
using the input uh x so that that's what
y
is so y is going to be the result um and
then the inputs and outputs are
generally related by a linear
or affine input output model and that
looks like this
this says that for example uh since we
think of x is the
uh another name for x is the actuator
that that's an old term old-school name
for it
um if if x is zero roughly speaking if
we do nothing
then the output would be b would be b
because you'd have a times zero plus b
um otherwise this affine model kind of
gives you what happens
if you choose the input to be x um
now these the matrix a and b they can
come they're known and they can come
from all sorts of things they could come
from first principles physics models
um or they could come from data fitting
right that you could actually just
fit uh a data uh to make this
approximately the right the
to make this equation approximately hold
now the goal in control
is to choose x um that determine that
determines y of course y is a function
of x
and we want to optimize multiple
objectives
uh that pertain to x and y and so that's
why we're going to use multi-objective
least squares okay so
typical primary objective would be
something like this
i have a desired output or target
output and my first objective
often is let's see how close can i get
to my target it measures my deviation
from the desired output okay
so and y desired here is given this
vector
um now a typical secondary objective
um is something like this it's often
just j2 equals
norm x squared and the rough idea is
that expresses our idea
that the input we put in should be small
right and this leads to some kind of
efficiency you want to get close to the
target
but you don't want to do it with a
gigantic x that's kind of the idea
or another way to do it is you'd have
some nominal uh
nominal input xnom and your secondary
objective might be not that x is small
but that x is close to
this x nominal squared by the way this
comes up in sequential
uh in sequential control where
you do this every every period or time
step or something like that
and a lot of times your secondary
objective x dom
is the previous control action and so
what j2 says
is please do what i like what i want to
happen
but at the same time please make my uh
please make my control action or input
this time
close to what it was last time and that
encourages smoothness
of your control actions over time okay
so this is the idea in multi-objective
control
let's look at a this is actually a
specific example of that although people
doing this would not would certainly not
call it control
but nevertheless here it is product
demand shaping so here's what's going to
happen is you have a set of end products
and you with a price vector p current
price vector which is positive
and we are going to change the prices by
this relative price change vector
delta price right so for example if i
told you that delta
price sub 3 equals minus 0.1
that means roughly speaking we are going
to reduce the price
of product 3 by 10
that's what that means right uh plus
means you increase the price
now that changes uh that induces if you
change the price of
a bunch of products it's going to change
the demand for them and these are
related by this
linear uh equation um here
ed is the e superscript d is the
elasticity price elasticity of demand
matrix um and it's a matrix where the
entries tell you
how much the change in demand you get
for a product
uh as a function of how much you change
all the prices right for for your for
your products
okay so that's that's your linear uh
model now here's what we want to do uh
somebody comes to us and says um i would
like
that's the target demand i want delta
target and
maybe that matches what what our
production capabilities
are um capable of producing so that
would have all our factories in our
supply chain running at
you know full tilt um anyway that's
that's the target demand
um so we would like the new demand
that's going to be or the change in
demand i should say
the change in demand should be near a
change in a target change in demand
and that's what j1 tells us so that's
the primary objective
now at the same time we want to get
close
to hitting our target change in demand
but at the same time
we don't want to we don't want to change
our prices like crazy and that's a
secondary objective that would be j2
and so that says you know please
trade off uh getting close to the target
change in demand
with while not if possible changing your
prices too much so that would be a very
common thing and then here we would
minimize j1 plus lambda j2
lambda is this parameter or some people
call it a hyperparameter
and we would adjust lambda and see what
happens and it's kind of clear what
would happen right
if lambda is very small it says
basically for all purposes minimize j1
it says get as close as you can to
delta the target change in
demand okay delta delta target
um by the way if e if e d here
is uh is invertible is invertible so
it's an n by n matrix if it's invertible
then basically as lambda goes to 0 you
would take the solution
which is just simply e d
inverse times delta target
okay and that would actually make this
thing your j1
0 okay so that that's how that would do
now
that might you know if this inverse uh
this so
this thing here um even if it's even if
a d is invertible
um this this could involve like very
large price change like plus minus 400
percent things like that
um by the way at that point it's not
just a question of you don't want to
raise your prices by 4x or divide them
by a factor of seven
um it's not just that you want to it's
also that this model is wrong
there um you know that model is is
supposed to be good
for price changes that are plus minus 15
let's say
um and it is not supposed it's not even
supposed to model what happens if you
double prices or triple them
or divide them by five so uh so this
secondary objective um is is there to
keep the price change from being big
okay now on the other hand as lambda
gets super big
we're just minimizing j2 j2 says
minimize
uh the change in prices and so what
happens is as lambda gets bigger and
bigger
this will suggest price changes that are
more and more timid
they are smaller and smaller uh if
lambda gets really big then delta price
as in the limit of lambda going to
infinity
we get delta price equals zero and that
says don't don't touch the prices
so this is kind of the idea okay and
so the idea is this this the whole the
whole setting
uh it's you're going to trade off the
deviation from the target demand that's
j1
um with the price change magnitude that
is gonna be
uh j2 okay so this is just another
example i would call it control
i think other people would not and
people who do this kind of thing would
definitely not call this control but
it's okay now i'll mention
actually a fairly advanced topic um it's
robust control but we can do it
um so um robust of course means
something
that is can handle changes and you know
uh so you would say something like oh is
your system robust to
something and something is some change
right um
you know that kind of thing so robust
control
refers to a control scheme that
is uh that can handle
uncertainty in the model so that's this
is an advanced topic but it's
well within scope of what we're doing
now so i'm going to tell you about it
okay so here what it is is a very common
way it's actually quite effective
what it is is that we're going to have k
different
input output models and these are
denoted with the superscript
here so um superscript
one and these are these are sometimes
called scenarios or sometimes
regimes like in finance you would hear
people say that like
which regime are we operating in um or
which scenario are we operating in
so here we have these input output
models it looks like that
and what it is is you're going to choose
a single x
and then the we interpret y superscript
k as
that's the output if the system model k
is correct that that that's what that
means um
that's what why superscript k is um now
notice it's kind of
it's interesting here right oh i should
say you know in-app in
applications these aks are i mean if
they're wildly different from each other
then
it's game over and you should just go
home because if someone says to me what
if you say what's your model and they
say here's my model
and they give you 10 models and they're
all completely different you're just
like okay
i quit there's no point you know even
going any farther
so normally in fact what the aks look
like is they're close to each other but
they're not the same
they're not quite the same right so for
example
if we if we actually obtain these models
by fitting
uh on data then these could be 10
different time this could be 10
different times that you fit the model
you fit the model on mondays data
tuesdays wednesdays and so on and each
time you got a model
and they're not quite the same they
might differ in the second digit
uh something like that and that that's
the situation you should think about
here
okay um so what we're going to do
is we are simply we want we would like y
to be
y desired so we'll take this objective
which is the deviation of y to y desire
but this is under the case scenario and
what we're going to do is we're simply
going to take
the mean square uh mean square deviation
something like this right so that's
that's how we would do this
um now i mean and it's interesting
because what it's saying
is uh someone said what are you doing
you say well i'm choosing an input x
and they go what's your goal and you go
well i want the output to look like y
desired and they go cool how do you do
it and the answer is well
it's a bit cut what you say is i don't
really quite know the relationship
between x and y
in fact it could be any of these 10
things so that's it
um and so what you're going to do is
you're just going to take the meat
you're going to make the mean square
error small so that's that's robust
control
and this will yield a choice of x that
kind of works well under all scenarios
i mean that's a i mean basically in a
mean square sense it's going to work
well in all the scenarios it's not going
to
you know just pick one and make that one
you know make one of these zero and the
others big
that's that's the idea so that's robust
control it's an advanced topic
but it's it's easy to understand it's
also
super super duper useful in practice